hi guys and welcome to yet another
trusting video by simply learn
in today's video we will learn about
command prompt which is an application
of windows system
in this video we will also learn about
the command tricks that can be used in
the command prompt
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from us
for today's video the agenda is
firstly we will understand what is the
command front application
continuing with how the command prompt
works
and lastly the command tricks
now without further ado let's begin with
what is command prompt
command prompt is a windows application
that requires a user to enter a command
for execution purpose
the command prompt is also a text based
interpreter
moving on we have command prompt working
the command prompt works as a command
line interpreter
which requires the user to enter a
command line in the terminal window
after that we have to press enter to
execute the function
command prompt also allows us to have
multiple windows open at the same time
with execution of different commands
the commands in the terminal window
allows us to access data about
settings related to our system
or network status
or booting sector commands
moving on let's take a look at the
tricks
for better understanding let's divide
the tricks in some parts
the first is network related
network related commands include network
status creating a wi-fi hotspot
obtaining an ip address of a specific
site etc
then we have general commands this
includes
clear option cut paste
changing the font and renaming folders
and lastly we have task and folder
commands which includes hiding a folder
sorting the lists of folders and gaining
a list of all the installed programs
to better understand the command prompt
working let's take a look at the demo
for the same
to access command prompt
go to search option
and write cmd
on clicking enter
we'll have a command prompt
to begin with let's take a look at some
of the general settings
for example
let's change
the name over here instead of the drive
and the user info let's type something
else
to do this we have to write prompt and
then the keyword we wanted to represent
for example
simply click enter
as we can see
the drive link and the user info is
changed to simply
now for example if we want to change the
title of a command prompt
that is represented over here
we have to execute the command
title
and the new title you wanted to
represent
in this case let's take trial
and the command prompt title is changed
to trial
to access much better options and
attributes regarding the
command we can use
help command
after help we should write the command
we need help with for example prompt
by doing this we can access different
attributes that are related to the
prompt command
let's
try then let's try adding greater than
sign
along with our
prompt name
for this we have the command
prompt
the keyword we want
simply
along with the attribute sign
which is dollar gene case of greater
than
and press enter
and here is the output
along with simply we have the greater
than sign
seems like we have too much output on
the terminal window
to clear out all these outputs you can
use a command clear
which represented by
cls
this would clear up the whole terminal
window
moving on let's try changing the font
color for the command prompt
to do this we have the command color
along with the attributes you wanted to
changed with
in this case we have zero nine this
would change the font color to blue
seems like the command works fine
but to better change the command we can
also do
color
help
this would give all the attributes that
are related to the color command
we can not only change the font color
but also the background color let's try
doing that now
to change the background color we have
to write the command
color
with
the color background to be purple
five
and the font color to be
red
which represented by four
seems like the command works fine
moving on let's take a look at some of
the network settings
for networking commands the most basic
is ipconfig
this command gives us an overview for
all the connection that are connected to
our system right now
all the wireless adapter lan ethernet
settings
ip address subnet mask and the default
gateway
this is all represented by the ipconfig
command
in any case if you want to copy all this
output
and paste it somewhere else
you can use a command
cut and copy
in terminal window it's quite difficult
if you want to select all this
and do control c it's not valid
so the command for the same is
ipconfig
then the pipe sign
with clip
on entering
this command would copy the output from
ipconfig
and now we can paste it to somewhere
else for example
on notepad
now as we can see the output is pasted
on the text file
let's clear up the window and move on to
the next
command for the next command we have
wi-fi hotspot creation
to create a wi-fi hotspot from your
system you have to write the command
net
sh wlan
set
hosted network
then is
mode equal to allow
space
ssid
which represents the hotspot name
let's give it
star
then we have
key which represents the password for
the hotspot
let's give it
password
123.
this command would create a hotspot
seems like we have some condition which
is
administrative privilege
to do this
access
cmd onstart menu
right click
and open the command prompt as
administrator
by doing this we have to again type the
whole command
plan
hosted network
mode
allow
along with ssid
which is star
and the password
as seen
the hotspot has been created
successfully
to start the hotspot we have to write
the command
net sh
wlan
start
along with hosted network
and press enter
this would execute the command and start
the hotspot
to stop the command
we have to write
stop
instead of start in the same
this command on executing would stop the
hotspot
now moving on let's try accessing a
website from the command prompt window
to do this write the command start
the address of the website
in this case let's take simply learn
and press enter
this would take us to the simply learn
website
command prompt also allows us to access
the ip address of a particular website
to do this write the command
ping
the name of the website for in this case
let's take
google
and press enter
this would give us
the ip addresses that are related to the
google website
moving on let's take a look at some of
the commands related to tasks and folder
to begin with let's take a look at all
the running tasks
on the computer right now to do this
write the command
task list
this command on execution would provide
us with a list of all the tasks that are
currently running
and seems like these are all the
programs or application that are
currently
on execution
to get a better understanding of the
applications and get a better detailed
result
try using this command which is
task list
with slash
b
on execution of this command
we will get a output with detailed view
of all the applications that are running
in any case if you feel like that the
output is too long or the process is
taking too much time you can do
control c
on execution of this command the process
would stop midway
now let's take a look
at all the installed programs in the
system to do this
we have the command
wmic
product
space
get space name
on execution of this command all the
list that is related to all the
installed programs would come up
this might take a second or two
and seems like we got our output
sometimes on accessing a particular
folder or a file in a command prompt is
too difficult as we have to write the
whole address
of the particular file or the folder
but
we have a shortcut method this method is
for example if i want to access this
file
directly open the file
and go to a subfolder
and on the title bar
click it and write cmd
this would open up a command prompt
window for particularly that folder
this way we don't have to write any
address in the command prompt line
and avoid any error
there are often cases when we want to
hide a particular file from a system
this can be done by accessing
the hidden option given in the
properties
by doing this
we can hide a particular folder
but in this case there is an option
available known as show hidden items
that is a drawback
command prompt terminal also allows us
to hide folders and it does not have any
drawback
similarly to the windows system
to hide a particular folder access the
file and write this command
at rib
plus symbol h space plus symbol
s space plus symbol r
then the name of the folder in this case
we have
example
pressing enter
on execution of this command we see
that the example folder is hidden now
and if we choose
show hidden options
there's no change
that means a file is secured now
to unhide the same file
instead of plus in the command earlier
use minus sign
minus h minus s
and minus r
and press enter
on doing this command the hidden file
would be unhidden
to finish up the video let's take a look
at some of the extra tricky commands
for example
shutdown command
this command would allow us
to shut down our system from the command
prompt window
to do so write shutdown
minus sign s
s represent shutdown
if you want to restart your system
write minus r
and in case you want to log out use
minus l
then we also have a condition the
shutdown system for example
typing
s
space
slash
p
along with the time
this command represents if you want to
shut down your system after 10 seconds
and in case you want to shut down in 60
seconds do 60.
in the same command we have another
variation
if we want to represent a particular
string on shutdown do this
slash
c
space double quotes and write your
string in the double quotes for example
going out
on execution of this command
the window will shut down along with
going out string represented
with this we have reached the end of the
video
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comment
section below thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here